[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el 19 de
marzo se celebra en el mundo el día del
sueño y tiene como objetivo sensibilizar
a la población sobre lo importante que
es dormir bien otro objetivo que se
busca es tratar las causas y síntomas de
la falta de sueño un problema que si no
es tratado a tiempo puede ocasionar
serios problemas de salud para hablar
sobre este tema quiero saludar en este
momento a erika quintanilla domínguez
psiquiatra de adultos especialista en
medicina del sueño doctora gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
dormimos - cada vez más muchos dicen que
duermen entre 4 y 5 horas le pregunto
cuánto debería ser el promedio para
descansar y no tener estos problemas de
salud
hola buenos días primero agradecer la
invitación
bueno efectivamente desde que se inventó
la luz eléctrica venimos durmiendo cada
vez menos y la recomendación de los
expertos y la evidencia dice que en los
adultos debiéramos dormir entre siete y
nueve horas esa es la recomendación en
general para tener un sueño adecuado al
menos en cantidad
ahora porque se subestima el dormir bien
muchas veces
durante muchos años en realidad aún no
se tiene absoluta claridad de cuál es el
rol en todos los ámbitos específicos del
sueño pero que se ha avanzado bastante
en comprender que el rol de sueño
fundamental de hecho el lema de este
esta conmemoración del día mundial del
sueño es sueño reparador futuro
saludable entendiendo que el sueño tiene
una función que va mucho más allá de al
día siguiente hacernos sentir
descansados sino que tiene unas
funciones por ejemplo en la regulación
inmunológica sabemos hoy día propósito
del cubil que la recomendación es al
menos uno o dos días antes previos y
posteriores a la vacuna para tener una
respuesta inmune adecuada con la vacuna
es recomendable dormir bien ya en la
regulación cardiovascular y la
regulación del apetito en la regulación
de nuestro ánimo de las funciones
cognitivas
perdón o sea si uno mira en todos los
sistemas en todas nuestras funciones más
allá del hecho de sentirnos descansados
o no el sueño tiene un rol fundamental
doctora usted bien lo hablaba es que
durante esta pandemia sobre todo en los
períodos de confinamiento se han visto
afectados los ciclos de sueño de las
personas cuáles han sido las causas de
estos transtornos y además cuáles han
sido las consecuencias si si durante la
pandemia lamentablemente bueno se han
visto afectada la salud física y mental
de muchas personas específicamente entre
el sueño no puede quiere decir que hay
básicamente dos variables que son muy
relevantes una que es la pérdida de
rutinas debido al confinamiento estricto
o al menos por las restricciones las
cuales en todos los países creo que
estamos sufriendo cierto ha hecho que
perdamos nuestra estructura nuestras
rutinas que nos permiten ordenar nuestro
día marcar nuestro momento de levantada
una manera regular entonces nuestros
horarios también de alimentación y
nuestros horarios de acostada cuando ya
no tenemos que desplazarnos largas
distancias por ejemplo no es necesario
que lleguemos a un lugar con cierta
anticipación para trabajar para de clase
todo esto hace que nuestra rutina se va
trastornando nos cuesta mucho más
respetar entonces
las recomendaciones en términos de
horario podemos dormir de alguna manera
en cualquier momento en los adolescentes
por ejemplo vemos problemas importantes
que se han desfasado con sus horarios de
sueño y que se quedan hasta muy tarde
con las pantallas ya en entonces desde
el punto de vista de los horarios de las
rutinas y el excesivo uso de pantallas
ha sido un tema muy relevante que ha
llevado a problemas en la alteración de
los ritmos de sueño y la ansiedad
también que produce el confinamiento en
las restricciones en el temor a perder
el empleo
enfermarme o si un familiar se enferma
gravemente también se asocia con
trastornos de la salud mental cierto y
del sueño sin duda entonces el insomnio
cobrará importancia y por último quizás
el tercer tema es que vamos de la mano
con los trastornos del sueño
específicamente con la apnea del sueño
es que la apnea del sueño un factor
importante es el peso y estos últimos
meses este año de confinamiento en
promedio los adultos han subido entre
otras vías y los doctorados gracias por
su tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 que tenga usted un feliz resto
de día ustedes gracias
[Música]